make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and
today i wanted to try something a little
bit
different just to switch things up and
add a little variety to the channel
because as we know
variety is the pepper of life or
something like that
anyway the inspiration for this video is
really twofold
the first of which is a comic that's
been published by marvel on and off ever
since the late 1970s called what if and
for those of you guys who don't know
what if was a series where the writers
would try to imagine an alternate
timeline of events than what would
actually happen in the main marvel
universe
and basically tell out of continuity
stories based on those hypothetical
situations for example there was an
issue that asked the question what if
spider-man had saved gwen stacy when she
was dropped from a bridge by norman
osborne they don't really use that many
words but that's more or less the gist
of the story and there was another one
that asked the question
what if wolverine had killed the hulk
during their first battle and basically
the writers of these issues
simply told a story based on this
alternate hypothetical set
of facts the other motivation behind
this is the fact that you guys keep
asking me to make videos like this so
i'm gonna make a video like this
i'm going to give this a shot we're
going to see what happens so because
marvel isn't really publishing what-if
comics really anymore i think the last
they did was infinity and they're
certainly not doing them an all-new all
different marvel and because of the fact
that seeing a marvel vs dc
crossover uh really or marvel and dc
crossover in the modern day
is really something that's kind of left
to the left of the birds i figured why
not fill the void
here on my channel and give this a shot
so with that in mind we're going to get
a little experimental today and we're
going to ask the question
what if the incredible hulk was given a
red lantern ring so in order to tell the
story properly
we have to know exactly what it is that
we're dealing with so in case anyone
watching this is not aware of what the
red lantern rings
are or how they work we'll start with an
explanation of their history
as well as the powers and abilities they
bestow upon their wearers
so back when jeff johns was riding his
character defining run on the green
lantern which we cover here every sunday
one of the biggest things he did was
create an entire emotional spectrum of
different lanterns
each one having a different color and
each color representing a different
emotion along the spectrum prior to this
we had only ever seen
green lanterns in comics but john's
expanded the idea of the lantern core
and made the green lanterns just one of
many aspects of a much larger picture
while the green lanterns derive their
ability from willpower there are other
lantern cores
that get their powers from other
emotions including the red lanterns who
rely on the emotion of rage for their
strength
now that brings us to the red lantern
power ring the source of power for all
red lanterns the red rings themselves
and the red lantern central power
battery were created by atrocitus out of
his rage and desire for revenge on the
guardians of the universe who he blamed
for the slaughter of almost every person
in his home sector drawing on the
central power battery the red lantern
rings imbue those who wear them with a
variety of powers and abilities but also
causes them to undergo a dramatic
transformation when the red lantern puts
on a ring the ring effectively replaces
their heart so that they can no longer
feel any emotion
other than rage and they're singularly
motivated to exact revenge and wreak as
much destruction as possible the ring
also transforms the blood of its wear
into basically a liquefied rage
plasma that the lantern can then
regurgitate and the blood that these red
lanterns regurgitate is both
incendiary and extremely corrosive now
red lanterns are also able to fire the
rage-filled plasma as an energy blast
with destructive capabilities
the extent of which is directly related
to the level of rage of the particular
person who's spewing this
and their power now other abilities
offered by the red lantern rings include
the ability to create like constructs
out of red light the durability of which
depends on the level of rage of the
lantern creating them as well as flight
and the creation of force fields that
both shield the lantern from harm
as well as sustain their physical
requirements as a form of life support
and so now that we've covered what a red
lantern ring does we next turn our
attention to what the incredible hulk
powered by a red lantern ring would be
capable of and to do that
we first have to run over what the hulk
can do without the ring so as most
anyone with any degree of familiarity
with the incredible hulk
knows the primary characteristic of the
hulk is incredible strength which
increases as he gets angrier and has no
known
upper limit this strength is
complemented by insane durability and a
ridiculously fast regenerative healing
factor
even in his base form the hulk is one of
the most powerful earth-bound characters
in the marvel universe but if we add the
red lantern ring to the equation
he becomes a universal threat the likes
of which would draw the attention of the
entire gamut of marvel's
heroes now the key factor to consider is
the effect that rage or anger is going
to have on a hulk
possessing the red lantern ring as we
said earlier the red lantern
ring is going to force hulk into a
physical transformation where his heart
and blood are replaced by pure rage to
the point that anger is the only emotion
he will be able to feel he will be
singularly focused on expelling that
rage in the form of violence
and getting revenge on all those who
have wronged him in the past it's
important to remember here that as the
hulk's rage level increases
so does his strength so what's going to
happen is essentially that the power of
the ring will cause the hulk to become
angrier than
ever before which in turn will cause him
to become stronger than ever before
when you add in other abilities granted
by the ring what we would be dealing
with here would essentially be an
invincible monster that can fly create
force fields and
shoot pure unadulterated energy out of
his hands and vomit from his
mouth so just think about that for a
second the hulk flying over a city
vomiting fire down upon the people below
that's
literally the situation that we're going
to be dealing with here so
now that we have an understanding of
what's going on we face the question of
how this story would play out
if it were to ever actually come to
fruition specifically how would the hulk
come into possession of the ring what
would he do once he got it
and how would he be stopped if at all
well of course the story would have to
start with some sort of crossover of the
marvel and dc universes so i think a
good starting point here would be that
we have a red lantern ring that's
recovered by shield
obviously no one at shield knows what
the ring is but like all lantern rings
it immediately
seeks out a worthy host arriving in
front of bruce banner making the
declaration
you have great rage in your heart you
belong to the red lanterns after which
banner immediately begins undergoing the
change
associated with the red lantern core of
course as he gets angry his
transformation into the hulk begins as
well in a matter of moments we have our
complete transformation as the hulk is
wearing the ring
vomiting his rage blood all over the
laboratory setting things on fire and
setting off all sorts of alarms this of
course
brings a multitude of shield agents down
on hulk who he dispenses with
easily now of course tony stark reed
richards and hate mccoy
all hear the commotion as well because
they're in this base of operations or
what have you but after seeing the hulk
destroy the shield agents they think
better of engaging him directly
noting that the last time he appeared to
be this angry it took an effort of the
entire marvel universe to stop him so
they formulate a plan to bring the
avengers the fantastic four and the
x-men together
as quickly as possible to take on this
new threat in the meantime
the hulk is just raging throughout the
city probably new york since this is
marvel comics after all
shrugging off an enormous assault from
the u.s military
unfazed by gunfire tanks airstrikes and
anything else they can throw at him i
mean
it's just absolute pandemonium like like
even from the civilian standpoint it's
just
absolute panic like old miss jenkins has
been going to the same church every day
for like the last 50 years
taking her groceries home looks up an
absolute [ __ ] and it's just like oh
lord jesus
you know just freaking out you know this
nice little old black woman freaking out
absolutely losing her mind now of course
this brings in the heroes of course the
fantastic four the x-men and the
avengers pretty much
every hero in the marvel universe comes
together to try and take down the hulk
so we get some pretty epic battle
sequences here
as all of these heroes unleash their
full offensive capabilities on the red
lantern hulk but something we have to
keep in mind here
is that we've seen before how powerful
and unstoppable the hulk can be
when he's angry during the world war
hulk storyline when the entire marvel
universe basically united
to stop the world breaker hulk that
version of the hulk was powerful enough
to take out
all those who stood against him
including doctor strange channeling the
energy of a demon
iron man and the hulkbuster armor the
entire x-men team ghost rider
and the century both of whom he battled
to a draw and while that version of hulk
was incredibly angry due to the fact
that he'd been unwittingly sent to the
planet zakar where he eventually became
ruler
felon love was in the midst of starting
a family when the planet was blown up
the level of anger would pale in
comparison to the red lantern hulk world
breaker hulk was able to feel things
other than anger he exercised restraint
he could have killed the x-men
during his battle with them but he
didn't because he didn't blame them for
the tragedy that he'd suffered
red lantern hulk would not be so
discerning he would be motivated by pure
unadulterated rage and would seek out to
destroy
everything and everyone in his path so
as the battle rages on
it becomes clear that the heroes are
going to fail civilians are dying
soldiers are dying
even heroes are dying on the ground we
cut to an exchange between
like some commanding officer of the us
military and captain america the officer
informs cap that the word has come down
from the president
that drastic measures are going to be
taken and a massive bomb
possibly even nuclear will be dropped on
new york to stop the rampaging hulk
before he moves on to other cities cap
grabs the officers radio implores the
powers that be to reconsider citing the
fact that not
only is hulk likely to survive the blast
but innocent lives will be lost
cap is told that the risks have been
considered and the president has decided
that the hulk represents the largest
threat to u.s
national security and all available
means would be taken to neutralize them
so
most of those heroes that have survived
turned their attention to trying to
evacuate the area before the bombs
dropped while some of the most powerful
heroes
attempt to carry on their battle with
the hulk eventually the plane carrying
the bomb is seen overhead the hatch
opens and the bomb is deployed as the
heroes on the ground
look up and [ __ ] they're shocked to see
that the bomb is caught in midair
by an enormous green hand yes suddenly
there appears in the sky over new york
the entirety of the green lantern and
blue
lantern cores the blue lanterns powered
by the emotion of hope use their rings
to negate the rage of the hulk
while the green lantern corps minus hal
jordan who's transporting the bomb to
the ocean or something like that are all
constructing
a cell of green light constructs to
entrap the hulk
because he's so filled with rage and so
powerful the hulk
initially resists the blue lantern's
efforts and smashes through the cell
created by the green lanterns but the
combined forces of the entire blue
lantern corps proves to be
too much and the hulk is finally subdued
now
following this battle we see bruce
banner in a shield infirmary receiving
treatment from the blue lanterns to cure
him of the effects of the red lantern
ring while how jordan talks with captain
america tony stark reed richards and
hate mccoy hal explains that in an
attempt to expand the red lantern corps
atrocitus had managed to find a small
hole in the barrier between the two
universes
but big enough to send a red lantern
ring through once the ring found its way
into the marvel universe
it chose the person with the greatest
capacity for rage which it deemed to be
the hulk once the green lanterns learned
of atrocitus plan
they enlisted the help of the blue
lanterns and together found a way to
enlarge the rip between the universes
enough that they could all pass through
as they knew the universe would not have
the knowledge or the ability to deal
with a red lantern
and so after banner's been healed hal
jordan takes the red lantern ring back
with him to the dc universe to be
destroyed and we end with stark and cap
checking on bruce banner when they ask
if he's okay of course he assures them
that he just needs to rest and when they
leave him in the hospital room to get
some much needed sleep
we zoom in on his face with the last
panel and we see a flicker of red light
appear in his eye before it quickly
returns to normal alright
what's going on guys this is rob and i
may be talking a little bit quieter than
i normally do but the reason why is
because
i'm in a hotel room i'm currently in
disney world and i'm getting ready to go
to epcot center which means there's
going to be a lot of alcohol being
drained today
but if you guys are seeing this video or
when you guys see this video
i will have just crossed 1 million
subscribers
so i'm excited i do want to say thank
you to everybody who helped me to get to
this point i do want to say thank you to
everybody who helped me to pull this off
it is a crazy
experience knowing that we're at 1
million subscribers and i never thought
we would have gotten this far
i do have a surprise for you guys about
crossing 1 million subs
and if you want to find out what the
surprise is you have to go watch the
ultimate weekly recap which will be out
on
tuesday i think over on comicstorian's
channel we've been building up to this
for a little while some of you guys who
are following me on twitter already know
what's going on i will say
14 individuals will be chosen to become
a part of what it is
that i'm building it's the rob core i
can't i can't keep it in it's the rob
core
i got rob core rings i got 15 rob core
rings and and i'm really excited about
it anyway
this video is going to be a test we're
going to do an experiment here last week
we did a video on what would happen if
the incredible hulk became the red
lantern we'll reference that in this
video
this video we're gonna kill him and
we're gonna test the waters and we're
gonna see which idea is better to do two
separate videos with a character
gaining marvel or dc powers whichever
the case may be and then killing them or
just combining them into one video so
like next week we'll talk about what
would happen if batman became venom
and then we'll probably just combine how
to kill him and how to defeat him in the
same video just to kind of test the
waters and see how you guys respond
we're just gonna sort of go with that
and we're gonna see
what happens but for those of you guys
who didn't see
my incredible hulk becoming a red
lantern video i will put a link to that
in the description so you can go back
and you can watch it but for those of
you guys who are brand new here
basically we did a what if storyline on
what would happen if hulk
got a red lantern ring and we entered
that story with the hulk defeated
but still alive but i know you guys
robcor i know you guys like the back of
my hand and the robcor ring that's on my
finger right now and i know
that you're not satisfied with just
defeating these ridiculously powerful
heroes no
no you want them off the board
permanently
yes so that's what we're gonna do today
now as we always do
we have to start with the discussion of
what red lantern hulk's powers
and abilities are now this might be a
little repetitive for those of you guys
who have already watched the previous
video but just bear with me while we go
over it for those who might be watching
for the first time so of course
red lantern hulk is going to have all
the powers and abilities that the hulk
would have
normally so as pretty much everyone that
has any familiarity with comic books
knows the hulk possesses
super strength that increases as he gets
angrier
with no known upper limit he also has
insane durability to the point
that it's nearly impossible to harm him
through conventional means and
in the event that he does suffer an
injury his insanely fast regenerative
healing factor
can more than make up for it now clearly
the hulk on his own
is formidable as he's probably the
strongest earthbound character
in the entire marvel universe but we've
already gone over how to kill him in a
previous video so that's why we're
throwing in the red lantern ring
simply to just make things harder on
ourselves so the red lantern ring draws
its powers from the rage of the person
wielding it and confers a variety of
abilities on its wielder with the most
notable of these
being the ability to regurgitate a
stream of liquid rage in the form of
corrosive incendiary blood now in
addition to this
the red lantern ring allows its wearer
to create hard-light constructs from red
light
the strength of which is determined by
the rage level of the wearer furthermore
the ring allows the user to create a
protective force field
fueled by rage and also allows them to
fly so if the red hulk
had the red lantern ring like we
discussed in the previous video that we
did on him what we're faced with is the
proposition of taking down one of the
strongest characters in the marvel
universe who we really can't inflict
any damage on and can heal from whatever
damage he does suffer that's also able
to fly and vomit corrosive rage blood
all over the place now in our previous
video
as i said we managed to defeat the red
lantern hulk but it took the entirety of
the blue lantern and green lantern corps
to do so
and that only worked after pretty much
every superhero in marvel comics had
failed to collectively take him down the
reason that worked is that the red
lanterns have an inherent
weakness to the blue lanterns which
derive their energy from the emotion of
hope that allow the blue lanterns to
drain the power of the red lanterns and
basically
that's how we defeated the hulk in our
last video by draining the power of the
red lantern ring that he was wearing
but now it's time to go a step further
and not only
leave the incredible hulk defeated but
to also
unalive also known as
advertiser-friendly word
the hook to that end we'll start with
the most straightforward way to kill the
red lantern hook this method
involves exploiting the physiological
transformation that takes place
in all those who put on the red lantern
ring for those that are unfamiliar what
happens when someone puts on the ring
is that the ring basically replaces
their heart as well as their blood with
pure rage
and the ring functions as a type of life
support keeping its wear alive
what that means though is that if the
wearer is separated from the ring
they will die since you know they no
longer have a heart which makes leaving
kind of problematic
but in theory if we can separate the
hulk from the red lantern ring he would
die
and we will have achieved our goal
simple enough right well
you guys should know by now it's not
going to be that easy
right it's not going to be that easy
first of all saying we're going to
separate the hulk from the ring
is one thing to do it is quite another
as we said we're facing a rampaging
invulnerable
rage vomiting monster it's not like
we're just gonna be able to walk up
and ask him to remove the ring right
like hey incredible hulk
you're really scaring old miss jenkins
man like she's terrified of you will you
please take off the ring
that's not gonna happen like he'll kill
us before we even get close enough
so we're going to have to figure out if
there's a way that we can separate the
hulk
from the ring against his will which
will be difficult
but might not be impossible so members
of the red lantern corps usually have an
inherent weakness to the hope
fueled light emitted by the blue lantern
rings exposure to this light will negate
the effects of rage
in the red lantern which in turn will
make them weaker now if we had enough
blue lanterns then it might be possible
to completely
neutralize the rage that burns within
the hulk and then once he's in an
extremely weakened state
remove the ring and in his life so in
reality
there really is a straightforward way to
kill the red lantern hulk although it
will take the concentrated power of
several blue lanterns but we can't say
for sure how many
because of course there's no precedent
for this in the comics
as hulk has never gotten a red lantern
ring what we do know though
is that hulk's capacity for rage is very
very high
so we can assume that it's going to take
a lot of blue lanterns perhaps even the
entire blue lantern core
to pull this off now i do need to point
out here that in our previous video
we did get the red lantern ring off the
hulk after he'd been defeated
and he didn't die now some of you are
probably wondering how that was possible
but the answer's simple
since the intent was to merely stop the
hulk rather than kill him
the blue lanterns would have used their
healing abilities to counteract the
effects of the red lantern ring on the
hulk's
physiology allowing him to return to
normal obviously if the goal is to kill
the hulk they wouldn't do that and the
hulk would theoretically die
when the ring was removed but let's not
stop there i mean this is a little
anticlimactic isn't it the rob core
is not about taking the easy way
out no no no all right we are not now
this nerd all right we're not taking
over the sourcefed nerd base
and then killing the channel that's not
our goal we're not going to destroy
everything that we built up we are going
to take the hard way out
we're actually going to work hard for
our money so hard for our money
and it's going to work hard for us so
since we've established that taking the
hulk down by dealing physical damage to
him is pretty much
impossible we're still going to be
focusing on taking off the red lantern
ring because
with it he's effectively unstoppable but
how do we get the ring
off of him the first step is clearly
going to be calming the hulk down we
have to decrease his rage if we have
any hope of getting close enough to
remove the ring to do that
we can try a couple of methods first we
can try to calm him down
telepathically there are several
extremely powerful telepaths in marvel
comics charles xavier emma frost jean
grey before she died and we can try to
use their abilities
to probe around the hulk's mind and turn
off the rage that's fueling him
this might work but it's not a sure
thing the hulk has shown in the past
that he is at least
somewhat resistant to telepathy now this
is kind of waxed and waned over the
years but the combined efforts of those
three telepaths
may be enough to overcome that
resistance but even then
i'm not sure how much is going to be
going on inside the hulk's mind it's
basically just going to be overcome by
rage
and devoid of any real thought maybe
this group of telepaths will be able to
dig past
all the rage and actually appeal to the
hulk's conscious mind
maybe they won't it's not a sure thing
but it is a possibility but i think a
better avenue than telepaths
is another class of characters that can
alter the moods of others
there are actually a few characters in
the marvel universe with this ability
such as
luna maximoff the daughter of
quicksilver and the inhuman crystal as
well as manual de la rocha better known
as the mutant
empath because he's a pretty obscure
character that many of you
may have never heard of empath is a
character that debuted in the mid-1980s
in the new mutant series
where he was a member of the hellions a
group of mutant students
taught by emma frost who at the time was
the white queen of the hellfire club now
he's been used
pretty sparsely in comics since then but
he is really the perfect tool for us
here
since we don't want to send a child like
luna into battle with the red lantern
hulk i mean it'd be messed up wouldn't
it like
to see like luna just go trotting up to
the hulk like hope will you please calm
down he's like hulk smash
like smash this little girl i mean it'd
be
i don't know why we're laughing that's
not funny
even we as murderous as we are we have
our limits right i mean
we have the limits of the things that
we're just not willing to do and sending
a little child in to get murdered is not
okay a teenager is perfectly acceptable
though because when i was a teenager i
was a dick and teenagers are generally
dicks
so empath is perfect because he's able
to control the emotions of others
without even touching them
and he can completely negate the
emotions that a person is feeling
and put them in a pretty much catatonic
state when they're in this state
empath is able to not only control their
emotions but their actions
as well so we let empath negate hulk's
rage
the hulk goes catatonic we take the ring
off the hulk
and he dies most likely i mean probably
there's a really good chance that he
will i mean
the hulk has an insane healing factor
maybe he can grow
a new heart before he dies maybe he
can't at any rate
we should probably just keep calming him
down until he completely reverts back to
bruce spanner before taking off the ring
then we can simply just shoot an arrow
through him and make sure that he can't
heal like when hawkeye did during civil
war 2 because marvel was making a stupid
decision but anyway rob kor
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the robcor
cropper uh if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like
and yeah let me know how you guys feel
about this do you like the idea of doing
a what if story
and then a separate video on killing
that particular character in that what
if story or would you rather see a what
if story
and the character killed in the same
video let me know down in the uh
down in the comment section and i'll
i'll try and experiment with batman or
something like that we'll
we'll do a what a story on batman and
kill him in the same video just to kind
of see how you guys
respond to that okay so i've had this
question proposed before because
normally we would cover a dc video today
but this is more interesting
so i've had this question proposed
before because we did the video red
lantern hulk what if the incredible hulk
got a red lantern ring
but the question that people have asked
is but what if wolverine got a red
lantern ring and it's such a cool idea
like for those of you guys who don't
know in in the green lantern mythos you
have the red lanterns which are
basically governed by rage kind of a
hallmark is that when a red lantern ring
is bonded to a person it
replaces their blood with this sort of
like red you know acidic plasma kind of
kind of substance and the result is that
they go forward as just like
these mindless killing machines you can
be cleansed by like a blue lantern but
for the most part
until then you're just sort of like a
mindless beast with wolverine it would
be a little bit different i think now
at like the outset right the gut
reaction would be well if wolverine
became a red lantern by whatever man or
whatever means he would just go on like
a blood fueled rage and just attack
everybody with his claws but here's the
problem with that if if that were to
happen
and wolverine were to just snap lose it
and just start attacking people somebody
would neutralize them pretty fast i'd
bet all the money in my pockets to all
the money in your pockets it would
probably be deadpool because deadpool
knows exactly how wolverine's healing
factor works because deadpool's healing
factor is modeled on wolverine's scaling
factor and so
most everybody like especially cyclops
of the x-men they know about like the
muramasa
blade which can be used to basically you
know cut wolverine and then shut down
his healing factor there's carbonadium
which can slow his healing factor i mean
there's a lot of different things that
they can do
to neutralize them and so because of
that because you're not talking about
the incredible hulk where you just have
like unlimited raw strength they can
just keep you know amplifying over and
over and over again to the point where
he just becomes this unstoppable
indestructible beast
i would actually switch things up then i
would say wolverine would not go on like
a blood fueled killing spree
he would still kill the marvel universe
but he would do it using guile and
stealth so wolverine as a character
has well really i mean he's been an
agent of shield he's been part of
multiple intelligence groups uh team x
he was part of that that black ops wet
work team before he was um before he was
rolled into the weapons plus program
he's been an avenger he's an x-man he's
he's played like all these roles he's
been like
basically in and out of every single
superhero team that exists in marvel
comics and so he essentially has
like the info he has the ticket of every
single superhero
and he knows how to take every single
one of them out and so from there like
like the question becomes
how do you stop wolverine from becoming
like a mindless monster
in truth i would invoke his healing
factor like i would say wolverine's
healing factor is this right like when
you become a red lantern your heart gets
replaced and
and that's the end of that but with
wolverine because he has a healing
factor i would say in this instance what
would end up happening is the red
lantern ring would bond to himself right
like something would happen wolverine
would freak out whatever it is you know
wolverine you have great rage in your
heart welcome to the red lantern court
so wolverine gets a red lantern ring and
then what you would see is this scenario
where he just kind of goes like
ballistic
for a moment in time for maybe like like
two minutes three minutes four minutes
whatever it is and then his healing
factor would take over and his healing
factor would basically like
push out all that red plasma blood stuff
it would essentially purify himself
it would regrow his heart and then it
would just be wolverine with a red
lantern ring now the cool thing is that
from there it would break out into like
constructs
and things like that it would allow him
to like use a red lantern ring to create
all these red lantern hard light
constructs now in reality
outside of like the rage and all that
kind of stuff and with regards to the
ability to make hard light constructs
there's really no difference between the
red lanterns and
any of the other lantern cores they can
all make hard light constructs it's just
red lantern constructs show up as red
but it's basically wolverine with a red
lantern ring now on the surface it
doesn't seem interesting it doesn't seem
like that great
but imagine what he could do with that
like imagine the the holy hell that he
could unleash
in reality like again i think he would
do it stealthy and guilty so the first
thing to do
would be to take out like small groups
groups that nobody would really notice
they'd take out like these these small
little villains here and there and
nobody would really notice that they
were gone at least not at first i mean
after a while because they're villains
to various superheroes superheroes would
wonder where they went to it would be
like okay we got to start taking out
people who are a little bit higher on
the totem pole
small groups per se like superhero
groups so the inhumans wolverine would
take out the inhumans first because
in reality the humans are largely cut
off like they're isolated from everyone
by the time people figured out the
inhumans were dead
nobody would really have any reason to
question it from there like it would go
into okay who does he end up taking out
next now this is where the caveat the
big issues begin to come into play
because then you start running into
things like the x-men the problem with
the x-men
is they're such a large group they're so
huge in size that what you end up having
is
at some point like almost immediately
people would begin to notice that the
x-men are dying and that's when i think
wolverine would basically start using
like
trickery and deception in order to pull
off this win so because he's creating
hard light constructs the question we
kind of have to ask here is can
wolverine make hard-like constructs and
send them after people without him
actually being there like what larfleeze
does for example larfleeze creates
orange-like constructs and then those
orange-like constructs can essentially
kind of think for themselves they're
basically autonomous but they're
composed of the spirits of people that
he's killed we could kind of invoke that
to a degree but i would say wolverine
may have to be there for a short amount
of time and so what you would do is you
would have him show up and basically
send the superhero community into
disarray and so he would show up to like
the xavier institute and kill everybody
who's there and then vanish and so
people would just be like what in the
world is going on like you know
literally all the x-men are dead but
wolverine's not seen anywhere now from
that point people would start to wonder
well if the x-men are being killed off
then like we have to go through
systematically and figure out who's
surviving and who's not and so you'd
have like the avengers you'd have like
the very superhero communities a
fantastic four so on and so forth who
would all start to sort of look around
and say okay you know what's what's
going on here and so wolverine would
basically have to like play into that
and just say like i have no idea what's
going on but along the way
you know he would say like we should all
basically start looking you know going
into our resources and seeing if we
can't figure out who it is that's that's
doing all this and so from there it
would turn into him like taking out the
fantastic fork it's like the fantastic
foregone and it would literally proceed
in that direction where it's wolverine
just like using a combination of
deception trickery and manipulation to
basically pit the superhero community
into finding out who this phantom
villain is more or less when it's
wolverine the entire time now in terms
of like invoking the hard light
constructs like those would only be
really used as like a plot device
those are there those are things that
pop up but they wouldn't pop up for very
long because i think that what you would
start to run into is especially with
someone like reed richards if they had
like
video footage of the hard light
constructs or there was some kind of
evidence of what the hard light
constructs were then people would ask
what are those and that's when you would
start to get into read and so on reed
richards and
iron man and probably blue marvel adam
berscher they would start to ask
questions on like what these constructs
are what they're made of and they would
start to investigate poke around
different things like that now what this
also leads to
is is questions like blue marvel himself
like adam brosher or like the century or
the incredible hulk these powerhouse
guys now because wolverine is so well
versed in the marvel universe because
he's so well versed with these various
superheroes we have to believe he would
know how to take them out the incredible
hulk is really like unlimited brute
force strength and so i could easily see
it being a scenario where wolverine just
like grabs like literally ensnares him
in a hard light construct and then just
like flies him into space and just like
kind of catapults him into the sun
it would have to be quick and dirty with
thor it's a little more complicated
because while thor
while he is a powerhouse in and of
himself the idea here is that thor
can technically he's done it for a brief
moment in time can like survive in space
now it can't be done for like a really
long amount
of time but it can be done for like a
short amount of time yeah now that i
think about it i want to say that in
thor
387 which i'm which i can't remember if
it was written by tom defalco
or walt simon said i don't remember off
top of my head regardless in that story
there was a point where thor
ended up in space and i think there was
a point where he was like i need to
breathe
but he could like hold his breath in
space i think it waxes and wanes i think
it kind of fluctuates like some writers
say he can breathe in space uh you know
space others say he can't i think some
say he can hold his breath for a really
long time uh we can kind of split the
difference
and just say that like he can hold his
breath for a while uh how long he can
hold his breath for
we don't really know but if we are
talking about like a red lantern
wolverine that has thor trapped in these
hard light constructs because thor has
mjolnir he'd probably be able to break
out of him with the incredible hulk his
strength would have to probably build up
to it but with
with thor like he's already at base zero
like he's already got his his hammer and
so he can just kind of start hammering
at the hard light construct until
eventually he breaks out i don't know
exactly how you would take out thor if
if you were a red lantern if wolverine
were to grab him and take off all the
way out you know it's like outside the
solar system and fly to like the other
side of the galaxy and drop them off
thor could could possibly make it back
it would depend on how far wolverine
took him out or wolverine could fly him
out could like
knock him out using a hard light
construct if he could like take him by
surprise like sucker punch him basically
and then fly out to the far side of like
the galaxy as fast as he possibly could
and drop him off and the idea could
possibly be that thor
would not be able to make it back to
earth in time before he suffocates but
then in that case he would just call on
like heimdall to use the bifrost and
then he would show up in asgard and then
come back to earth and that would be the
end of that it's this quick
teleportation system more or less so i
don't know exactly how we would defeat
thor
i mean if we use the old version from
like the 1960s and we said that if he
loses contact with his hammer for more
than 60 seconds so he had that donald
blake concept then all it would take is
for like wolverine to take the walking
stick and like chuck it into space
and then like just kill donald blake i
mean that's all you would really that's
all it would really take but
i don't know the thor aspect would be a
little more difficult um the sentry i
think could be done much the same way
as like the incredible hulk the same
thing with blue marvel um you literally
just kind of like
throw them out there send them floating
out there throw them in the sun or any
number of things what could also be done
here this is actually okay so here's a
really cool idea
what do you could do with thor the
incredible hulk like with the heavy
hitters
is if he goes and kills the fantastic
fork wolverine's not the sharpest tool
in the shed but he does know how to
activate a portal so what he could do is
he could activate the portal to the
negative zone and then like
okay yeah then go to the heavy hitters
and just be like hey i think i found the
person who's killing everybody who took
off to the phantom zone we have to go or
to the negative zone we have to go find
them and then like when they open the
negative zone portal just like close it
behind them and then just like leave
them stranded in the negative zone
there's no way for them to break out the
only way to get in and out of the
negative zone is to use a portal that
would allow your energies to cross
either that or you could like push them
through without reversing their polarity
and they would disintegrate deadpool he
would he could throw on the sun deadpool
would be done like that that would be it
the x-men i think the the full brunt of
the x-men i think would be the most
difficult thing or i guess the mutant
population because even
if you're talking about like the core
x-men roster that's taken out of the
xavier institute you are still talking
about some pretty powerful beings who
are out there it would just kind of be
wolverine taking them out individually
like using his claws like popping his
claws then just kind of slashing at him
so on and so forth and calling in a day
captain america of course would be one
of the first people to go just because
captain america would be able to kind of
like rally the superhero community
together um i feel like iron man like
the really smart guys would have to be
some of the first people to go because
they'd be able to use their intelligence
to decipher pretty quickly what all's
going on now what this does is it leaves
shield now in reality shield can be
taken out pretty easily like it wouldn't
be that difficult to eliminate them
because you're talking about this
great big huge hulking monstrosity of an
organization like an intelligence agency
i mean captain america did it with the
greatest of ease in secret empire i mean
he just tricked everybody into believing
that he was a good guy and they made him
they made him head of shield so i mean
it's not the most difficult thing to do
uh with wolverine having previously been
an agent of shield he would have privy
to like all their internal files and
like all the information and databases
that they have
and then from there like set focus on
shield itself taking out the directory
would be step number one because if no
one knows who they're taking direction
from then the entire system comes
crashing down
that would pass to number two so on and
so forth and he would have to
systematically break into shield destroy
their systems or computer systems he
would he would just kind of have to go
through and start killing various people
individually now this leaves nick fury
who would probably go hide in a bunker
but in reality if there's really no one
left for nick fury to rally then it
really doesn't matter in the first place
just because he's alive doesn't mean he
can actually do anything if there's no
real way for him to stop anything and
then yeah like it would literally just
be wolverine going through
systematically and just taking out each
member like each group in the superhero
community using like stealth and
and you know guile and deception all
that kind of good stuff it would
definitely make a cool story like it
would definitely make a
make a cool like what if story like what
if wolverine became a red lantern and
like killed the whole marvel community i
mean we know that from like the enemy of
the state what if like where wolverine
kills the marvel universe like we know
about that
that video will be down in the
description by the way but we know we
know he can do it
even with justice clause i mean i don't
know it creates an interesting situation
then the question would become what
would like a lot of the villains do like
what would a lot of the villains do if
they realized what was going on
in the old man logan story mysterio used
his powers to trick wolverine into
thinking that the various villains of
the x-men had attacked the xavier
institute all the while wolverine was
killing the x-men so i mean it's a
little bit different when you're doing
that but like when mysterio casts an
illusion to trick wolverine into like
realizing hey look everything's done you
defeated everybody time for you to give
up now you know i mean
is that what would happen you know like
would the heroes and villains band
together to stop wolverine i mean that's
that'd be an incredible story like that
would be an amazing story
what's going on guys this is rob and do
you all remember when we used to make up
our what-if stories i don't remember if
we did that many of them i know we did
what if red hulk became a red lantern
and i know we did what if batman became
venom but i don't know if we did any
others besides those
but like you guys have constantly been
asking for more of like these what-if
stories because here's the here's the
thing marvel does have a what-if line of
comics right for those of you guys
weren't familiar with this
marvel really used to have a title
called what if right they basically
looked at alternate reality versions of
the stories that existed in their main
universe which basically allowed them to
be more adventurous in the stories that
they told because the what if stories
did not take place in the maine marvel
continuity right so it was like what if
spider-man stayed venom what if
punisher's family had not been killed
that was the kind of stuff that we saw
but making up our own what-if stories
allowed us to do stuff that marvel's
never done yet right
like neither marvel or dc have ever even
done yet right with dc's elseworlds with
marvel's what is so we can make up our
own thing
which is always kind of fun and so in
this video
we're going to be covering what if
thanos got
all the lantern rings in the dc universe
what if he went to the dc universe and
gained
all the lantern rings now thanos is a
character that we always associate with
his quest to collect
all the infinity stones it makes sense
for an interesting proposition
for him to basically want to also
collect another set of items that would
grant him
even more power than he already
possesses but i think that we need to
start with why thanos would want to do
this in the first place
what's going to be his motivation for
collecting these rings is he just like a
jewelry aficionado wanting to like add
some rare pieces to his collection is he
trying to flex on folks they see me
rolling
they hating patrolling they trying to
catch me riding dirty trying to catch me
riding dirty
trying to catch me riding dirt i don't
know that's that's what he's wanting to
do right
[Laughter]
that would be awesome right just like
finish like rolling around and like some
some cadillac with like pink leopard
skin on the seats
and stuff like that that'd be baller
right it's like a ball in thanos i
remember seeing an image like that
floating around somewhere where he was
just like blinged out it was insane
right he looked like
he looked like a rap artist like it was
it was absolutely insane uh but i think
that
what makes the most sense here for this
story is to play on thanos infatuation
with death and his constant struggle to
win her approval i picture this starting
out with a conversation between the two
of them with thanos basically saying
that he's killed all that he can in the
entire marvel universe and asking what
else you could possibly do
to win the hand of mistress death and so
it's then that she informs thanos of
another universe with billions more
souls to claim for her and then opens a
portal to the dc universe now i know
it's not the strongest
instance right it's not the strongest
thing to go with just go with it right
that would never happen you know like
it's comic books right like the
incredible hulk being able to breathe
underwater was never able to happen
until it did right so like just roll
with it
[Laughter]
just have fun with this but thanos would
basically step through this portal
and did we flash forward to the present
where we find that thanos is on a ship
with sinestro on board and what we find
out is that thanos has been in the dc
universe
for months and has not only learned of
the existence of the lantern rings but
has also decided to acquire them all
thinking that doing so will make him a
white lantern thereby granting him
immense power and increasing his ability
to cause death and destruction and in
doing so
finally win him favor in the eyes of
mistress death
so to help him accomplish this task he
enlists the help of sinestro who's made
a deal with thanos in exchange for a
promise that the mad titan will help him
obliterate the green lantern court and
so we also learned that their alliance
has already paid off with thanos having
acquired three of the rings already and
we basically end up getting these
flashbacks
where thanos had basically left the star
sapphires the indigo tribe and the blue
lantern corps in complete ruin noting
that he was able to overwhelm
and defeat each of them without much
trouble at all and so at that moment
sinestro would chime in
and say that would not be the case with
your next foe
and he basically explains to thanos that
they're traveling to the homeworld of
the red lantern corps to confront their
leader atrocitus now undaunted
thanos would basically tell sinestro to
set a course for the red lantern
homeworld and so when thanos arrives
atrocitus is basically there waiting for
and we get to see our first epic fight
of the issue with thanos and atrocitus
doing battle now as you may know the red
lantern ring is powered by rage
an atrocitus has that in spades and is
able to basically
mount a substantial fight against thanos
but as strong as he is he pales in
comparison to the power of thanos and
ultimately falls in battle and so thanos
would take the ring of atrocitus and
make his way back to his ship where he
would essentially remark that the
abilities this ring granted were quite
impressive and then imagine what a more
worthy being could do
with such a weapon and so sinestro would
provide a little bit of insight there
and basically say that it's powered by
rage
and thanos would basically reply by
saying that's something that he that
he's not in shortage of right and so
sinestro would say good
you're gonna need it to take on
larfleeze and so then we get to thanos
and sinestro
landing on the planet of okara the
homeworld of larfleeze himself the only
orange lantern in existence
now once thanos steps off his ship he's
immediately attacked by larfleeze
triggering
another epic battle for thanos now much
to thano's surprise larfleeze presents
even more of a challenge than atrocitus
being able to channel the entire energy
of the orange central power battery
itself now the two fight
for a pretty lengthy amount of time like
they would need to given the amount of
power that larfleeze has with thanos
who'd basically be using the red power
ring the entire time
but larfleeze is essentially able to
match him blow for blow and then
suddenly out of nowhere
larfleeze's ring would basically shut
off and thanos would capitalize on the
opportunity to take his life as well as
his ring and so as thanos would turn
around he would see sinestro wielding
the blue power ring and the sinestro
would basically explain
that the ring has the ability to negate
the effects of the orange
power wing and then of course that also
be kind of pissed off and be like why
didn't you tell me that in the first
place
and so senator would probably be kind of
a dick about it and just be like i grew
bored and i figured i'd get in on the
action if the opportunity presented
itself
later on sinestro would overhear thanos
seemingly talking to himself as he
passes by his quarters and then would
stop to listen
and it would become clear that thanos is
talking to somebody else bragging about
the great warriors that he's slain in
her name
but then also remarks that he believes
that sinestro is withholding information
from him and does not believe him to be
as trustworthy as he first seemed and so
the next day
thanos's ship would hover over owa which
was of course home to the green lantern
central power battery and he would ask
sinestro like is the green lantern corps
here and so sinestro will reply and just
be like well they will be the moment you
attack the central power battery the
green lanterns will rush to defend it
and then of course you'll be able to
crush them of course now
thanos feeling like sinestro is a bit
sus would basically say well
i mean i don't have all the rings yet
and like i was supposed to wield the
power of the white lantern before i
launch this attack right and so sinestro
would hold out his hand and open it and
in the palm
is a yellow lantern ring and would
simply just say my gift to you
by my calculations there will be dozens
perhaps hundreds of green lanterns here
any moment and so surely you can relieve
one of them
of their ring right and so thanos would
land on owa and make his way to the
central power battery and as he draws
near he's stopped by a detachment of
around half a dozen green lanterns who
basically tell him to get back on a ship
and leave and that more of them are on
their way and this is probably one of
the coolest moments right thanos is
known for trash talking and so he would
basically say
when they get here maybe you can use
your rings to fashion a green shovel to
dig the graves of your fallen comrades
it's an awesome line isn't that awesome
[Laughter]
that would be amazing right so the green
lanterns would basically ready
themselves for battle and they would
fight valiantly but now in possession of
a yellow orange and red ring
thanos would prove to be too much for
all of them and so as the ring of one of
the fallen green lanterns goes to take
off and try to find a new host
thanos would grab it seize control of it
and basically dominate the willpower of
the ring
and make it his own and then basically
say the final piece he needs to finish
his collection and harness the power of
the white lantern would essentially make
him the most powerful being in the
galaxy
and so once he puts on the ring nothing
happens right and so at that moment
thanos is confused and angry and then
sees a laughing sinestro and so thanos
would be kind of pissed off he'd be like
you treacherous fool like what have you
done
and sinestro would say i have not done
anything mad titan it's your own
shortcomings to betray you
acquiring the power rings alone will not
make you a white lantern you must master
all the emotions of the spectrum to
wield that kind of power
wrath fear avarice even willpower you do
not lack but
hope love and compassion these concepts
are foreign to you and the power you
desire will always evade your reach now
predictably thanos
would be pissed right like he'd be mad
as hell and he would head towards
sinestro but sinestro would basically
point to the sky where
thousands of green lanterns are entering
owa's atmosphere and so of course
sinestro would tell thanos where he
would ask him
sixth green lanterns were not enough to
stop you but six
thousand even a being as powerful as
yourself will not be able to withstand
their assault and so thanos would
ultimately know that sinestro's right he
would know that he basically has to
leave owa immediately but of course
before he does he crushes the head of
sinestro with his bare hands and
retribution for his betrayal before
getting on the ship and essentially
leaving
now as the ship takes off the green
lanterns would land on owa and hal
jordan jon stewart kyle rainer and all
the familiar faces would be among them
now of course jon stewart would look at
thanos leaving and simply say
we're too late and how jordan would
respond he'll be back and we'll be ready
for him here we cut to thanos seething
on a ship but then we end up hearing a
voice that comes out of nowhere right it
just basically says
thanos of titan you have proven yourself
a great warrior and a conqueror of death
come to me and i will give you power
beyond your wildest dreams right so
thanos is like who the heck
is this who am i talking to and this
voice identifies itself and says
my name is necron but you can call me
death
[Laughter]
how awesome is that right so necron
would basically go on to explain that he
is the counterpart of mistress death
in the dc universe and since thanos has
been dead
and come back to life he offers him a
black lantern ring which he'll basically
use
to collect more souls than he ever
thought possible now of course thanos
would basically accept this
offer as he's completely obsessed with
death and figures that once he has
basically extinguished all life in the
dc universe
death will finally move him out of the
friend zone
and so thanos takes the black lantern
ring goes to several planets and lays
waste
to all of them building himself an army
of reanimated corpses
before he returns to oahu to finish off
the green lanterns once and for all now
what we end up finding out when he
arrives is that sinestro had begun
working to sabotage his plan from the
moment he heard him talking to death and
figuring out that thanos was eventually
going to betray him
sinestro had contacted hal jordan and
told him of thanos's plan
to unite all the rings and correctly
predicted that thanos would fail and
then would ultimately discover the
existence of necron and the black
lantern corps
due to his fascination with death and so
sinestro would tell hal that he knows
what to do
and hal would agree and so when thanos
would land on owa he'd be met
by basically the entirety of the green
lantern court but with his
army of the undead with him he would
basically have the numbers
advantage and so the green lanterns
would fight valiantly but thanos's
forces are essentially gaining the upper
hand until house springs his plan
and trades his green lantern ring for a
yellow one kyle rainer would trade his
green lantern ring for a blue ring and
guy gardner would trade his ring
for a red ring and so thanos would see
this and then mock them all derisively
right stating that he'd basically killed
red yellow and blue lanterns and would
have no trouble doing it again and so
that at that point hal jordan
would chime in right and he would say
you have learned to wield the rings but
you don't understand them right you are
powered by death itself but we control
the light and light always drives out
darkness and so the group would
essentially work in tandem with green
blue red and yellow
fighting side by side against the black
lanterns and much to thano surprise he
would end up
losing control of his forces and so how
would then monologue while he's kicking
the crap out of thanos and would
basically say that he knew that the
green lanterns alone could not win the
fight but that when willpower is in the
presence of one or more of the other
rings the effects of the black lantern
ring can basically be negated and so he
called upon members of the green lantern
corps who had wielded
other rings in the past and asked them
to do it once again
in order to stop thanos and save their
home world and so after a hard-fought
battle the lanterns would emerge
victorious destroy thanos black power
ring and then imprison him within the
central power battery on oah so that he
could probably break out
and battle the justice league in a
future storyline and so the story will
basically end that like back in the main
marvel universe
mistress death would be calling up
deadpool
to see if he's still single as her
calendar has recently become
unexpectedly
open what's going on guys this is rob
and today we're back with another what
if video and since we've done videos in
this series featuring the red lantern
rings and the orange lantern rings i
thought i'd focus on the black lantern
ring now this is probably the last one
we're gonna do at least as far as the
lantern rings for a little while
it's like good charlotte once said one
time is okay two times is fine
three times you're playing with yourself
so we're gonna stop after three and then
we're gonna kind of call it a day or at
least
we might come back after a while but
we're gonna do a what if story on
something else next week but in thinking
about who would do something interesting
with a black lantern ring i came to the
conclusion that the best candidate for
receiving this ring would actually be
magneto now that might not seem like an
obvious choice but i think it makes
sense because magneto has a very
specific objective that he's basically
been trying to achieve
since we were introduced to the
character the overthrow of the human
race and the establishment of a new
world order where mutants assume their
rightful place of dominance over mankind
and although magneto is extremely
powerful
being an omega level mutant in his own
right he's never been able to achieve
this on his own and so it makes sense
that if he were to gain access to
something that could give him a
significant bump in power that he might
actually be able to accomplish his goal
also i want to set the parameters for
the story in terms of where in the
marvel chronology this hypothetical
story would take place
and so i definitely want this to take
place before the current x-men status
quo
of all the mutants living on krakowa and
being able to resurrect dead mutants
went into effect and i think the best
place for this story to occur
is just before the events of avengers vs
x-men and the vision that i have for
this is that it'll actually take the
place of avengers versus x-men because i
think a lot of people were fairly
underwhelmed with that story or at least
underwhelmed with the versus portion of
that story i kind of was the versus
series was cool because you got to see
x-men fight avengers but i felt like it
was one of those things where marvel
started off strong they were like yeah
this is gonna be awesome right issue
number one is gonna be amazing by like
the six versus issue it was like okay so
like we're done now and like they didn't
care they were just kind of like
stuff things and stuff then that was
basically it but the first thing we have
to figure out is how magneto gets his
hands on a black lantern ring at this
time
magneto is actually a member of the
x-men but his alliance with the x-men
has always been a bit tenuous as some
members of the team have a hard time
getting past the fact that he's tried to
kill them like a million times which is
fair so as it turns out their suspicion
is justified and it turns out the
magneto is not 100 committed to xavier's
dream
of peaceful coexistence between humans
and mutants and that he's actually been
meeting in secret with the scarlet witch
who at this point was still canonly
recognized as being the daughter of
magneto scarlet witch as you probably
know is an extremely
powerful magic wielder and in this story
we learned that her abilities have
actually grown to the point that she's
able to travel between dimensions and as
part of her alliance with her father
she's been looking for powerful
artifacts to aid his quest
for mutant supremacy now you could
probably guess from the premise of this
video that one of those artifacts
is the black lantern ring and so she
travels to the dc universe
learns about the ring and then takes it
back to magneto who keeps it in his
proverbial back pocket until the perfect
opportunity to use it presents itself
now another thing that happened in the
x-men line of comics at this time
was the impending return of the phoenix
force and its anticipated union with
hope summers its chosen host now the
conflict over what should be done about
this
set the avengers and the x-men at odds
with one another with the avengers
wanting to prevent the phoenix from
possessing hope and the x-men welcoming
it as a rebirth of their species
in this version of the story however
instead of allowing war to break out
between the avengers and the x-men which
he fears will lead to the unnecessary
deaths of many of his fellow mutants
once the avengers make known
their intentions to take hope into
custody magneto dons the black lantern
ring and sets in motion the eradication
of mankind to pave the way for a world
where mutants reign supreme without fear
of interference from humanity now once
he wields a black lantern ring magneto
is able to reanimate the dead and use
them as his own personal army his move
is to go to the ruined island of jenosha
which was once a mutant paradise to some
16 million mutants inhabiting it but was
ultimately reduced to rubble and most of
its citizens killed by cassandra nova's
wild sentinels and just by going there
magneto is able to raise for himself an
army of
millions of slain mutants which not only
has symbolic significance because it
turns the greatest massacre of mutant
kind into a weapon that could be used
for humanity's undoing but also makes
magneto and his hordes of reanimated
mutant zombies the most pressing threat
to the marvel universe
unfortunately for him this is also the
thing that causes the x-men and the
avengers to put their differences aside
and unite against this new threat the
avengers
still think the phoenix force needs to
be stopped but that must be dealt with
after magneto's zombie horde is defeated
now the x-men do not respond to
magneto's tactics here as although they
do want a resurgence of their species
they are totally unwilling to side with
magneto in pursuing what amounts to
genocide and so rather than hailing him
as their savior as he had hoped the
x-men find themselves in the familiar
role
of casting magneto as their greatest
villain and so the x-men and the
avengers divide into strike teams to
respond to the several attacks that
magneto is orchestrating around the
globe
meanwhile professor x iron man black
panther doctor strange
namor and reed richards known
collectively as the illuminati
meet to try and figure out a way to
neutralize magneto's newfound power now
after some discussion they go their
respective ways hoping to find anything
they
can to stop magneto eventually doctor
strange returns and explains that he's
followed the trail of magic
unwittingly left behind by scarlet witch
which led him to another dimension where
he learns about the black lantern rings
and how they can be defeated now after
explaining that there were rings of
other colors in that dimension capable
of negating the power of the black
lantern rings he also explains that he
was unable to bring them back because
bringing too much of that universe into
this one would weaken the barrier
between them and could open them up to
all sorts of new threats instead he
explains that it's the emotional
spectrum that's really the most
effective weapon against magneto's black
lantern ring and that the rings are
really just conduits through which
emotional energy is channeled and so
determining that willpower and
any other strong emotion will negate the
effects of the black lantern ring the
illuminati formulate a plan
to tap into charles xavier's telepathic
ability to alter the emotions of others
and project these emotions psychically
to their teammates that are on the
ground fighting against magneto zombies
and so black panther and iron man work
on a way to try and reconfigure cerebro
to be able to boost the emotional signal
being sent out by xavier xavier is also
going to be boosted by fellow telepaths
emma frost and her step for kakoos as
well as hope summers whose mutant power
is the ability to copy
or enhance the powers of others and so
while this is going on the x-men and
avengers are actually fighting these
zombies and taking heavy losses the
zombies can be killed but only if
they're killed quickly enough that their
bodies cannot regenerate furthermore
if they aren't able to bite someone
they're able to turn them into a zombie
as well
and so we've seen several heroes falling
in this manner once the illuminati put
their plan into place however and xavier
starts using his abilities to inspire
willpower
and hope into the minds of the heroes it
actually seems to be working and the
heroes begin making headway and taking
out the zombie horde however something
goes completely wrong when hope goes
into shock which greatly weakens the
signal of xavier's psychic boost
to make matters worse magneto is able to
raise more and more corpses
faster than the heroes can destroy them
and so they begin to become overwhelmed
in a battle of attrition
cutting back to hope it quickly becomes
clear that what the avengers had feared
and the x-men had hoped for has finally
happened and the phoenix force has
returned to earth and claimed hope as
its host now the shock and fear of the
phoenix's return
quickly turns to optimism as the
phoenix's attention is clearly focused
on magneto and his forces and so
ultimately the zombies are
incinerated by the phoenix and hope
seeks out and locates magneto now as
they stand face to face magneto tries
desperately to explain
that their missions are aligned but hope
completely shuts him down stating
that she's come to bring life and that
he's given the planet to death and so
she destroys the black lantern ring
purging the marvel universe of his
corrupting presence before explaining
that while she is able to keep the
phoenix force in check for now hope is
fleeing earth in order to figure out
what degree she's able to control it and
so she flies off into space leaving the
avengers and the x-men to try to deal
with the fallout from magneto's attack
as well as prepare for what happens if
hope is unable to control the phoenix
and comes back to earth first
they discuss what should happen to
magneto with each side arguing that they
should be the ones responsible for
taking him into custody as captain
america and cyclops argue
wolverine enters the picture presumably
to act as a mediator but everyone is
shocked when he pops his claws and cuts
magneto's head off on the spot everybody
looks at him and he says that he's tired
of magneto duping the x-men into
thinking that he's changed when he never
would
now that'll never happen again and he
turns in his avengers card
and renounces his membership in the
x-men sick of being torn between the two
competing factions and wanting no part
of any upcoming conflict between the two
teams
ultimately he says when hope comes back
i'll know and if she's not in control
i'll be able to do what i need to do and
with that he walks away to forge his own
path
independent of either team all right
what's going on guys this is rob and
today we are taking
one of the most fearsome characters in
the marvel universe
and asking what would happen if they
were to gain possession of one of the
most powerful artifacts in the dc
universe the orange lantern ring and i
think the first thing that we have to
work out is how does galactus acquire
the orange lantern ring in the first
place
so surely everyone who's watching this
knows the deal with galactus that he
goes around the universe devouring
planets because that's the only way to
satiate the intense hunger that he feels
now to help him do this he's employed a
series of heralds to find planets
suitable to consume and the current
herald of galactus as of the time this
video is coming out
is thor now we are going to make a
couple of assumptions here right as most
of you guys know
thor is currently the herald of galactus
in order to help him find a handful of
planets that will allow him to consume
the black winter and thor's response is
however many people on those planets die
it's not the biggest thing because the
universe is at stake here so basically
the needs of the few outweigh the needs
of the many what we're going to assume
is that under any normal circumstance
that thor serves galactus in a starkly
different way
than as has been done by heralds of the
past in the sense that thor has a much
stronger moral compass than any of the
previous heralds probably even stronger
than silver surfer and that thor is
going to do everything he can to make
sure that galactus takes as few innocent
lives as possible
and so the idea is that thor goes to sif
who's taken over for heimdall
as the guardian of the bifrost following
his death and tells her to try and
locate planets that are devoid of
innocent life that he can direct
galactus to now due to some sort of
cosmic anomaly stiff is able to extend
her vision beyond the boundaries of the
marvel universe and locates a planet
called okara which is just
bursting with energy but seems to have
no innocent life on it at all and so
thor thinks that this is basically
perfect and he tells galactus about this
planet and then they go to it now
immediately galactus is like this planet
shouldn't be here something's definitely
wrong i assume that's how galactus talks
at this point lar flees the orange
lantern approaches galactus and
thor and is not about to let this planet
be consumed without a fight now thor
initially considers moving in since he
knows the planet is inhabited but he
immediately senses that larfleeze is
anything
but innocent and he knows that now
galactus knows about okara that he isn't
leaving without feasting on his energy
and so we basically get an epic battle
between thor and larfleeze which goes on
for a while without either able to gain
the upper hand
until galactus decides that he's tired
of waiting and blasts lar flees back
down to the planet's surface
and then begins consuming the planet now
not long into this process however
galactus starts noticing that
something's wrong
that this is not like any energy he's
ever consumed in the past
and that it's changing him and so we
know this due to the fact that the
orange power battery is housed on the
planet
and galactus is essentially tapping into
that power now still galactus finds
himself unable to stop
feeding on that energy in fact he wants
to devour as much of it as possible
and so when he's absorbed the entirety
of the planet's energy
including the orange power battery
galactus is transformed into an
orange lantern and this spells disaster
for the entirety of the marvel universe
now
in addition to his nearly insatiable
hunger galactus is
also motivated by insatiable greed just
a bit of background on the orange
lantern corps for those of you guys who
aren't familiar with it the orange
lantern light represents greed on the
emotional spectrum and so anyone who
dons an orange ring or taps into the
orange power battery
is motivated only by greed from that
point forward
now usually this means that they simply
want to hoard as much stuff as they can
but galactus is really beyond material
possessions and so i thought it would be
an interesting twist that instead of
desiring things
he ends up desiring as much energy as he
can consume going well beyond what he
needs to survive
and so he sets out across the marvel
universe leaving a trail of broken
worlds in his wake now realizing the new
danger that galactus poses to the
universe thor rushes back to earth to
warn the avengers teammates who quickly
call in the fantastic four due to their
prior experience with galactus and so
thor describes what happened
but reed richards is unable to come up
with any plausible explanation as he's
never heard of any kind of orange light
capable of transforming someone
into a voracious greed monster and so to
try and find out more about this
mysterious force
reed goes with thor's space to the now
dead planet okara to see what
information they can gather
and reed soon realizes what galactus did
that okara should not have been
in the marvel universe that it was
clearly from a different universe based
on the readings reed was getting but the
opening in space time that allowed it to
travel to their universe no longer
appears to be open
and so reed ultimately states that he
was hoping that he could access the
place that the light originated perhaps
they could find something there to help
them rid themselves of it now as readers
we know that in fact
something does exist in the dc universe
that would help their newfound problem
the blue lantern ring which is able to
negate the effects of the orange lantern
ring and so reed sets to work trying to
find a way to reopen the doorway into
this other universe but in case he fails
a contingency
needs to be in place and so while he
works on finding a way to the dc
universe the avengers and the fantastic
four will seek out perhaps the only
artifact in the marvel universe
that will be able to stop galactus the
casket of ancient winners
that's not true that's a dumb idea it's
the ultimate nullifier
but the ultimate nullifier for those of
you guys who don't know is a device that
is said to be the only weapon in the
universe which galactus fears
however since the nullifier also appears
to be part of galactus he can recall it
to himself
seemingly at will and so the team will
have to sneak aboard galactus world ship
to retrieve it without him knowing and
so what happens is that the heroes split
into two teams thor takes one team
consisting of invisible woman
she-hulk captain marvel and captain
america to galactus world ship
tattoo to retrieve the ultimate
nullifier while reed richards and the
black panther try to devise a way to
reopen the gateway to the dc
universe and the thing stays behind with
them to fly them back to the place the
gateway was after they figure it out and
so the human torch also volunteers to
accompany them on their mission
suggesting that if anyone could survive
the trip between universes it would be
him
due to being able to exist as a pure
form of energy now because reed and
t'challa
are extremely smart and because in their
intelligence they realize that they need
to move the pod along they find a way
to recreate the cosmic anomaly that
opened the door between the two
universes that can only be explained
using the most ridiculous comic book
science terms imaginable
just that's that's what we need we just
need like like when they're like read
how did you do it he could just take a
page out of like i don't like the flash
tv show right when they're like barry
how'd you do that he's like speed force
man
i ain't got to explain it like it really
needs to be the same way right it's just
like reid how'd you do that
science and like that's it that's all
you get and so they go to the planet
okara and attempt to reopen the gateway
now they are initially successful in
reopening the gateway but when the human
torch goes through it much to the terror
of his companions he's vaporized before
their very eyes
not only does this doom his plan to
failure but it makes reed wonder if
perhaps galactus destroying the universe
would be preferable to trying to explain
to his wife
why her brother's atoms have now been
dispersed across the universe
i wouldn't want to have to do that but
we cut to thor's team and their attempt
to procure the ultimate nullifier now
thor is the first to enter galactus ship
under the pretense of meeting with
galactus to plead with him to stop his
rampage and spare the universe this is a
tough pill for thor to swallow but he
also puts his pride aside and plays the
role knowing that galactus needs to be
distracted so that the ultimate
nullifier can be secured without his
detection
now as the two of them argue with
galactus telling thor to find him more
planets to devour
because he must acquire all the energy
he can the rest of the team
enters the world ship an invisible woman
becomes invisible and begins searching
for the nullifier now after a short time
she finds it and then takes it but doing
so
sets off an alarm and galactus brain as
a part of himself has now been taken
from him and so galactus blasts thor
through the wall of the ship and into
space while the rest of the avengers
team
escaped the ship with the ultimate
nullifier now as they make their way to
their ship they find that mr fantastic's
team has joined them outside of galactus
ship but he's joined by most of the
cosmic heroes in the marvel universe the
silver surfer beta ray bill the
guardians of the galaxy
nova pretty much all of the heroes you
can think of now reed explains that
things on his end went south and he put
out a distress call that was answered in
droves
reed takes the ultimate nullifier from
sue and explains what happened to johnny
now sue's heartbroken but there's no
time to mourn because galactus is
pretty pissed off and the only option
they have is to fight and so it's an all
hands on deck situation
with even the earthbound heroes donning
spacesuits and venturing off of their
ships and into the battle there was a
lot of firepower here with heroes like
the silver surfer and thor
aided by the power cosmic captain marvel
nova and
others and for a brief moment it looks
like they may be able to mount a
meaningful defense against galactus but
then everything suddenly changes when
galactus summons an army of
orange-like constructs now unbeknownst
to our heroes but known to us as the
orange lantern ring allows its wheeler
to absorb the energy from its victims
and transform them into hard light
constructs which they can then command
as an orange lantern core army of sorts
and so in the case of galactus this
means
that he has billions and billions of
these soldiers at his command as he's
consumed
multiple planets after absorbing the
orange lantern battery and so as heroes
begin to fall before galactus horde reed
realizes
that the plan was doomed before it even
started that galactus will win if he
doesn't do something drastic and he
readies the ultimate nullifier for
detonation
knowing that everyone in the vicinity
will likely die but that the universe
itself may still be saved and so before
he can detonate it however
it vanishes from his hand and reed and
the surviving heroes turn around
to see none other than the living
tribunal himself now for those of you
guys who may not be familiar with a
living tribunal he's considered the
second most powerful entity in the
marvel universe behind only the one
above all
and his job is to judge and correct
anything that may throw
off the cosmic balance of the marvel
universe and so when he shows up
you know it's serious business and so
all the fighting
stops as galactus simply just awaits
judgment and so the living tribunal
explains that he cannot allow the
ultimate nullifier to be detonated as
galactus is a necessary element of the
cosmic fabric of the universe and that
erasing him from existence
would have catastrophic consequences
however galactus greed fuel rampage
throughout the universe
also threatens the cosmic balance of the
universe and cannot be allowed to
continue and so the living tribunal
strips galactus of the orange power
battery
and he hides it away in a pocket
universe that he created so it can never
be accessed again
he declines however to bring back
johnny's storm or resurrect any of the
planets galactus has devoured as he
determines that the universe can
function perfectly well without them and
that he's not one to intervene
unnecessarily and so with galactus no
longer under the control of the orange
light he goes back to fulfilling his
role
as normal and the heroes that survived
the battle go back to earth or wherever
it was
they came from to mourn those that fell
now here's the cool thing
i imagine a lot of you guys probably
thought that we were going to bring back
johnny's storm right that like johnny
storm was like he vaporized like we
didn't really vaporize he just kind of
disappeared
he's in the dc universe he rattles the
blue lanterns and then brings like all
the blue lanterns to
the marvel universe and they save the
day wrong i thought it'd be awesome to
like totally do a 180 and just like like
spin you guys on your heads
i thought it'd be cool what's going on
guys this
is rob and uh we're back to creating our
own what if stories
which i think is especially important
now because marvel and dc are not
releasing any news stories which by the
way let me know what you guys think down
in the comments post
some stories that you think we should
cover we are going to get caught up on
x-men but aside from that let me know
what stories you think we should cover
because i'm considering covering
execution or song there's no
significance about the story
but it is cool and strife is like strife
was amazing
strife man immature so if they
introduced strife for the marvel
cinematic universe
man dude it was man it would be it'd be
a massacre anyway uh so we're covering
the story the x-men become
red lanterns so let's begin this right
let's begin this let's put this story in
the context of the greater marvel
universe so as you know
if you've been reading any x-men comic
lately the x-men along with all mutants
on earth both good
and evil are currently residing on the
living island of cocoa or at least most
of the mutants that are out there now
since jonathan hickman took over the
x-men line of titles the mutants have
established their own nation on kokoa
and their relationship with other
governments of the world has been
tenuous to say the least now this really
comes as no surprise and is more or less
a microcosm
as how the world has approached the
mutant race since their introduction
into the marvel universe as being
hated and feared by humans has basically
been the underlying theme of nearly all
the x-men stories that have ever been
told so that gives us a really
logical starting point for our
hypothetical story as now that the
mutants have their own country the other
nations of the world
have an easy target for the prejudice
against homo superior now one of the
prominent features of the x-men status
quo on krakowa is that any time a mutant
dies they are to be resurrected through
a process
involving a group of mutants known as
the five tempest proteus hope
summer's elixir and egg who was formerly
called gold balls but somehow finds
himself with an even lamer nickname now
but the whole process
relies on egg essentially creating
non-viable eggs which proteus turns
viable through reality warping dna of a
mutant is then injected into the egg
which elixir gives life to
tempus then speeds up the incubation
process with their time altering powers
until it hatches and all of this is made
possible by hope summers empowering the
rest of the five to use their powers in
unison and at the peak of their
potential through her ability to mimic
the powers of others and push them to
their absolute limits and so for our
story to get off the ground
this process has to stop happening as
this is going to provide a catalyst
that's going to cause the x-men to
choose the path of becoming red lanterns
so what happens is that a covert team of
operatives from an unnamed organization
finds their way to kokoa in the cover of
darkness they destroy the stockpile of
eggs that have been created to resurrect
mutants and kill egg himself so that no
more eggs can be created thereby ending
the process
of mutant resurrection however the most
egregious action taken
is the assassination of charles xavier
now while this has happened before
since the founding member of the nation
state of kokoa this time
there is no bringing xavier back and as
you would expect the idea that they can
no longer employ this process to raise
their fallen as well as the murder of
one of their own is a source of great
anger for mutant kind
though as the council that governs kokoa
gathers they decide that the human
community has gone too far
and that although they respect the dream
of charles xavier for mutant and human
coexistence that prompted one of the
principal laws of kokoa to be
kill no human the time for that
cooperation has basically passed and
they must now set their sights on
revenge
however the council knows that lashing
out at the world will draw the
intervention of the non-mutant heroes of
the world and they debate on how
or even if they can defeat them now it's
at this point that apocalypse reveals
that he's been making contingency plans
for the day that his fellow mutants
finally saw the light and realized that
peaceful coexistence between mutants and
the inferior species of humanity was
impossible and so he explains that he's
found a way to use the doorways on kokoa
to go beyond traveling from place to
place to be able to travel between
dimensions and in fact he's been making
periodic trips to another universe and
has found an
ally in an entity called atrocitus now
he goes on to explain
that although atrocitus cannot come
through the gateway to cocoa since he
is not a mutant that he's given
apocalypse a number of rings that will
grant the mutants
vastly more power than they already
possess what's more
apocalypse would say smugly these rings
are fueled by
rage and when have we of a species ever
been more enraged
than at this moment if we take these
rings no force on earth will be able to
stand against us
and we can finally take our rightful
place as the rulers of this planet so i
feel like apocalypse would talk that way
but i don't know like
i don't see i don't know how to voice
apocalypse he doesn't really need to be
loud but he doesn't really need to yell
he just needs to have that authoritative
voice but normally cooler heads would
prevail and the x-men would never do
something like this but
their mentor and their entire way of
life has been destroyed
in an instant and they are
understandably angry and the presence of
the rings apocalypse has offered them
seems to only intensify their rage and
so those who were closest to xavier
magneto cyclops wolverine
storm jean grey and basically all the
x-men take the rings and recite the red
lantern oath as instructed by apocalypse
with blood and rage of crimson red
ripped from a corpse so freshly dead
together with our hellish hate
will burn you all that is your fate and
so those words prove ominous as once the
rings are dawned the x-men are
transformed in a way
turning into creatures motivated and
consumed solely by rage with an
insatiable desire to destroy
everything in their past no longer are
they out for revenge for their fallen
leader but simply an all-consuming need
to watch the world burn and so from
there that's what they set out to
accomplish
indiscriminately traveling the world
leaving as much death and destruction in
their wake as they possibly can
now when news of the rampage of the red
lantern x-men reaches the rest of the
superhero community
that just sounds awesome red lantern
x-men like that just sounds amazing
now when news of the red lantern x-men
uh reached the rest of the superhero
community they immediately tried to
defies a way to stop them the avengers
the fantastic four
spider-man doctor strange literally
every superhero you could think of comes
together to try and stop the x-men's
wrath
they meet the x-men with a united front
sparing no resource
in their offensive against their former
allies which have now been turned into
mindless monsters iron man and black
panther have brought out every piece of
technology and weaponry they have but
the plasma emitted by the x-men
incinerates it all as well as the
entirety the entirety of wakanda's
forces
doctor strange scarlet witch brother
voodoo every magic wielding hero in the
marvel universe and even doctor doom
who's temporarily aligned with his
traditional enemies to save his kingdom
of liveria and the rest of the world
launch every magical attack they can
think of to no avail despite
the potency of their magic the force
powering the x-men
is not of this universe and the magic
seems to have no effect on the red-light
constructs
shielding the x-men now as the battle
rages on the heroes of the marvel
universe begin falling
one after another before the red lantern
x-men those that are left begin
formulating a last-ditch plan to save
the world
it's a long shot and something they
would never do under normal
circumstances
but they see no other option and so reed
richards tells thor who's still serving
as a herald of galactus to find the
devourer of worlds and bring him to
earth
and furthermore to take franklin
richards with him thor does not like
this plan richards and and read writers
would respond i don't either thor
but this world is gone either way we
cannot defeat them but there is the
lesser of two evils you'll just have to
trust me and so thor will respond
i as he would fly off with franklin to
summon galactus now in his absence
the heroes would fight valiantly but
they would continue
to fall spider-man captain america and
iron man are all among the dead even
heavy hitters like captain marvel and
the hulk
are unable to do any significant damage
to the red lantern x-men when the battle
is over the red lantern x-men hover over
a smoldering earth having destroyed it
all but in a cruel twist of fate
still not satiated and craving even more
to destroy although nothing remains and
so when thor reappears
galactus appears with him and so a thor
would say alright eater of worlds
do it now with that galactus would
consume the planet and
everyone on it bringing earth 616 to an
end once and for all now as galactus
thor and franklin look at an empty spot
in space where the earth once resided
franklin sheds a tear for his family
that have basically just been
wiped out of existence now thor would
say i thought your father said that you
could fix it and frankly would say
i can i can make things exactly like
they were before it will all be just
like it was and no one will know
except for me and so with that franklin
richards makes the earth in the image it
had been before the x-men put on the
rings before charles xavier was
assassinated and before apocalypse
figured out how to cross into the dc
universe and learn of the red lantern
corps furthermore
he creates a barrier between this
universe and that one determined to keep
the corrupting force of the red lantern
core or any other force that may attempt
to infiltrate their universe from ever
seeping in again
and so this universe has enough problems
of its own and ultimately
franklin richard just kind of lets
things go so yeah that's how i see it
playing out if the x-men ever got the
red lantern rings i think they would be
virtually
unstoppable and would lay waste to the
entire marvel universe so that the
easiest way to right that ship would be
to eliminate the earth they destroyed
and replace it so that no one would ever
remember what the x-men did and this is
kind of a cool thing here there was this
idea that i was kicking around with that
when galactus and everybody showed up
that ultimately there would be like a
spare red lantern ring floating around
there somewhere who really knows but
like the red lantern ring would bond
itself to franklin richards and franklin
richards will become a red lantern ally
himself with the x-men
take on galactus defeat him and then
they would just kind of go out into the
universe and try to destroy
everything if you guys want to see that
story where franklin richards becomes a
red lantern let me know like let me know
and i will make that video because i
feel like it would be
lit like it'd be amazing right franklin
richards as a red lantern
would be so opie
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explain to make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
incoherence
[Music]
you